looking backwards I think that the curb
appeal of the great quadrangle Linna
prestige to the institution that made it
great before it was great if you it was
a really smart move and the architecture
was well worked out and the great lawn
was a marvelous idea we used to drive in
to the symphony and we will drive down
mem drive coming from Fitchburg on route
2 and then down the drive and we would
have a lunch at Howard Johnsons that was
up where the hotel nuh is now and so we
went past MIT on our way to longfellow
bridge and so I I knew the school and I
like science in high school and I guess
that that way I just didn't think of any
other school that was my choice MIT was
very remote for people that lived in
Cambridge even though we lived almost on
top of it it we had nothing in common
with them I don't even think when we
were living in new town court that they
had dormitories at that point talking
about MIT honestly I never knew that
they moved to cambridge okay I always
thought they was here and started here
okay of course they've been here longer
than I have so that's why I thought you
know it was always originally here the
uniqueness of it being on the river
makes it something you almost can't miss
because the child's river and the Boston
skyline just is unbelievable but even in
the beginning MIT was it was just so
popularly known
that you always marveled at it you know
your drive by mass ave and you see the
big columns and the stairs and you go
wow and you know you think massachusetts
institute of technology technology you
know it's it was something great okay
when I grew up we just got TV you had to
wait for the TV to heat up so technology
was what you saw happening and you new
technology was MIT and that they were
part of it